[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm linked this week at the roundtable
of dim lighting it's still not that dim
and we're still not at the table because
we're still at our own home how you
think the table is doing gonna last the
table I'm just sitting in there in the
studio just oh I'm sure it's able fine
yes doing good man it's lonely sadly
like a lot of people these days don't
mean to start on the downer we are going
to talk about the silver lining we're
gonna try to be positive and we're going
to look to the future and what type of
impact does this experience going
through weathering this virus what what
lasting effects is it gonna have what
ripple effects is it gonna have how is
it gonna impact the future of our lives
indefinitely and like you said I think
in a in a positive way cuz I mean one of
the things that has been helpful for me
as I get anxious get fearful get
frustrated with the fact that we're you
know cooped up in the house is to think
about the good that will come from this
and I do I think there's gonna be
there's quite a bit that's quite a bit
to be excited about in terms of the
future it's growing yeah we've got a
number of thoughts related to different
categories as I'm as I'm adapting to
this new lifestyle of staying at home
with my immediate family I'm I'm
starting to take note of things it's
like wow this is this is different but
it's not worse this is better I wonder
if I'm gonna keep this habit even after
things change so you know I've got a
number of things that that I'll bring up
and then you know what this can serve as
kind of like a time capsule episode
where we go back to and we see how right
or wrong we were did you have any bold
predictions that you're prepared to make
well i my prediction is that at some
point I won't be in the corner of my
living room making this podcast as is
evidence just by the fact that right at
the beginning of this recording when I
got when I which I had to do every time
we get ready to do anything in here is
I'm like okay guys I'm recording and
then the thing that came back was one
person said noise I think my wife said
can't we live our lives and then I think
my son said why don't you do this in the
garage so again
the family has still not adapted to
what's happening even though I am yeah I
hate to drive it and you're not calling
fires anymore I'm talking about your job
yeah what being increasingly you know my
job is is actually an important part of
the family dynamic now my wonderful
beautiful wife is standing at the top of
the steps down into our sunken living
room and just staring at me incredulous
ly because she's listening she looks
great she's got her Jason Isbell shirt
on that has a dinosaur on it
why are you reducing her to only what
she looks like well I'm not doing that
I'm did I just know I know what she
likes I know how she likes me to talk
about I love you I love all of you I
love all of you you're all great now go
away well one of the things that I have
been that has been an immediate change
for me is the way that we're approaching
food I think this is the case for people
all over the world now we are in a very
privileged position because we still
have access to all the food that we want
essentially right I mean you may not get
as many things as readily as you got
them in the past and we're making do
with a little bit more we're cooking for
ourselves a lot more than we normally do
we're eating leftovers which this is
gonna sound pretty privileged
but we most of the leftovers our house
get eaten by the adults yeah I'll get
leftovers right my kids are spoiled
rotten man
they're like Halle leftovers if another
day comes the next day comes and we're
like we're having leftovers the look of
grief and disappointment on my
children's faces it's just a sign that
they're spoiled rotten but now that we
don't have a choice at this point we
would have a night of the week that
would be leftover night and we tried to
make it into something that would seem
more like an event like Kristy would say
things like it's leftover night you know
in it and your how that goes
cheer it's not usually cheers no but
yeah there now there's a heightened
sense of okay there's a little bit of
this left I'm a couple where that thing
up and I'm gonna put it away and then
you're you know because you just don't
know when you're gonna get some of that
from the grocery store again like a
little bit of we had I mean we are
occasionally ordering takeout it's a
stressful time especially after that
media that Ellie sent around Ellie
shared a video there's this one doctor I
guess he's in Seattle who he's had a few
videos go viral but he talks about what
you should do when you bring groceries
home in which when you bring takeout
home and and I've shared that video with
will you know our friend chat group
which Jessi forces in and she was like
you cannot share this video with someone
who has OCD because they will just go
down this rabbit hole so I said and
never come back I'll be the one to be
responsible for the disinfection process
when things come to the door it's very
it's very stressful I mean it's one
thing when you've got like a couple like
two bags that carry out but it's another
thing when you order groceries and they
show up like yesterday we had groceries
show up which by the way we had ordered
probably five or six days in advance and
so you're you're trying to figure out
what you're going to be out
and you're gonna you're trying to figure
out well if if they don't have this then
they're gonna try to substitute if they
don't have anything I'm trying to get
something else just so we got we have
well-rounded meals now Christy handle
that order but I knew how stressful it
would be when all that was dropped off
at the door that I was like out I'll be
on the front lines of kind of bringing
this stuff in and you you know we we got
this whole system like we clean off the
counter and then you bring it in you put
all the bags on the floor and you take
the stuff out of the bags and you put
them in a unsanitized pile throw away
the bags and then spray down and then
wipe down every square inch of
everything that's prepackaged that
that's potentially been handled that's
coming into the house I mean it's it's a
you know it was it was a lot of
groceries so it was like four five
people so it's like a half-hour process
to get this thing done and it's very
stressful because you start to feel like
you start to feel like you're you're
you're exiting some sort of nuclear
contamination zone you know it's and I
to me I mean that's one of the first
things I've been thinking about is as
much as I overthink everything now I've
been thinking about the level of
contagion how easily things can be
spread and all the things that I'm
touching it's I mean this is this is I'm
sure a common experience to a lot of
people and I just don't know if that's
gonna go away when this when this virus
is in the past well you know I'm I'm II
am I am I gonna be a fist bump er am I
gonna be a am I gonna be somebody who
brings in the groceries and wipes them
no you're nothing I'll be wiping no no
no because I'll be on that would be
irrational I mean they wanna know but
but I will be thinking about it more
often yeah well I mean like not not
handshaking or touching people first
well yeah let's wait let's wait to get
into that because I think that there's a
whole conversation
we can have about like what this means
about proximity to people and like
greetings and stuff but like going back
at the groceries
I mean first thing I will say it because
I don't want to alarm people I don't
want people to think that the process
that you just outlined is necessary for
everybody because you know mode most of
the the research or the research
suggests that the virus does not easily
spread through takeout food or through
groceries but that doesn't mean that
there isn't a risk it just means that
it's significantly lower risk then
actually being in the proximity of
somebody who is infected and breathing
in like an actual you know droplet this
is not air but that doesn't mean that
there isn't some risk so if you want to
eliminate the risk or minimize the risk
then you can go the extra mile not doing
you you sound like you're doing exactly
what the guy subscribed to described in
the video he got all the way down the
video I'm gonna do exactly was in the
video yeah but he was washing each piece
of fruit for 20 seconds with soap you're
not doing that are you uh Christy
handled that stuff so I don't know if
she went that far we're just being
really did like we're trying to like
leave the external bags and we're doing
takeout like once to twice a week we're
trying to minimize that but leaving
those external bags on the porch and
then when you can kind of empty out the
contents of a package onto a plate or
something like that and then throwing
away that and wiping everything down
sticking to hot foods instead of cold
foods it I just what I'm trying to do is
just mitigate it minimize it but knowing
that you can't really eliminate the risk
but I mean the thing that scares me more
than anything is much is like if I have
to be in close proximity with somebody
which I really have it the only during
this and so we're recording this on what
is it the 31st of March that we're
actually recording it yeah
and so obviously you're still in
lockdown lockdown spin sort of a federal
lockdown has been pushed through the end
of April California will probably go
longer than that I saw
that the governor of Virginia is said
there was gonna be a lockdown through
June 10th subject subject to be updated
but he went ahead and said to June 10th
stay at home order basically the only
the only thing that I've done is there
was that one time I had to go over to
the creative house to accept the
delivery of a desk my desk finally came
in and I like metal got go well I met
the guys out in in the front and I
stayed I was like 20 feet from these
dudes outside and I was like alright
guys here's what I'm gonna do I'm going
to describe to you I'm gonna I'm gonna
go inside I'm gonna open up the doors
and leave them open so you can walk in
I'm gonna come back out I'm gonna
describe to you with a room and the
location that I want this desk to be
setup in and then I'm gonna go into the
back yard and I'm going to wait these in
other words I don't want to be in the
same house at the same time because I've
been doing good yeah about this
quarantine thing yeah you know first of
all they the two guys who were
delivering in setting up the desk
volunteer they were like well we don't
have it and I was like I didn't say
anything like well you typically a
symptom that you could be the 25 percent
or more people who are asymptomatic who
have it but are still contagious or you
could be the 100 percent of people who
usually get the disease and have it or a
systemic for the first two days but also
are contagious but I didn't I didn't
break that out I didn't want to be that
straighting that it's just not getting
through to people well that's another
thing we'll talk about is people's
inability or unwillingness to process
the facts around this stuff but anyway
so I said I said all that and then I'm
in the backyard
and they got he's like a sir and like no
they've run into a problem and I and I
and I kind of like stick my head into
the living room and I can see in the
hallway and I can see that they've got
the desk sort of like stood up and
they're like this desk is not going to
fit into that we can't get it in there
and he was like I've been doing this for
13 years and at that point I ain't gonna
happen I took a deep breath and you told
him
just put it in my room well actually
certain I know no I I explored this
option I was gonna do this without you
admission I was gonna put my desk in
your room and just switch our offices
and see if you ever noticed but it's not
it's not the location of my office it's
the it's the width of the doors in the
creative house are 29 inches which are
too small to get anything in there so
you're there's no room that it could fit
in except the living room so I told him
to take it back but before I told him to
take it back I went up to them I held my
breath and walk into the house you know
I can hold my breath for quite some time
I had a conversation without breathing
which I have been practicing lately
which we've discussed yes and I was like
okay it by the time I was run out of
breath that was all right you're right I
don't think this is gonna fit
I just returned it and then ran outside
yeah my faces turn I probably did
breathe inside a little bit so but you
know that was it was a week ago and I'm
still feeling okay I mean I I get as
much delivered as possible but I order
takeout from this one place and I I went
to pick it up I mean I I'd done this
before and you know you go in and
they've got a rack and your stuffs on it
you've already paid there's no touching
to credit cards or even signing of
anything you just take it but some
people they're not they haven't figured
all that out so I get there and it's
like I got a sign a thing I know I
didn't want to sign a thing now I'm
touching this pin yeah what the hell why
are they what is wrong with people man
I don't know whether you figured get
with the program figure it out and then
even worse it they they have this coffee
bar and that's where you went to pick up
the stuff but there was a guy sitting
you should have just said I'm not buying
it by the way say screw it what are you
gonna do sue me I'm not signing it I
signed it and I had my antibacterial
spray and I immediately sprayed myself
and walked out and sprayed myself again
spray my hand you know but sprayed
myself there was a guy there was a guy
who had gotten
Coffee and they gave it to him in a
to-go mug and then he sat down in the
aisle where everyone has to pick up and
he's like just within a few feet of
people and he's an older guy and he's
talking to everybody that comes in
because I don't know maybe he lives
alone he's probably lonely he just sat
there and they should have told him he
had to leave and Here I am I'm like am I
the one to tell this guy sir you really
don't need to be here for that for your
health and the health of other people
everyone has to come in too close
proximity to you and you're talking your
and your what's the word when you like
you boom your voice you're projecting
you're projecting your voice so that
people can hear you at a distance which
is projecting stuff into the air man
it's like well just to give you an idea
this is why I didn't talk to the guy
because if I started talking to him I
didn't want to get angry with him yeah
so I didn't say anything well and so
there might be people who think that in
that we're gonna talk about this there
much as people who think that we're
overreacting that we're overreacting
that the experts are overreacting but
just to get what you're talking about
with the projecting of the voices so did
you hear about the chorus group that got
together 60 people got together like you
know a week or two ago I don't know
before everyone really understood that
maybe two three weeks ago before anyone
really understood the seriousness of
what was going on they got together for
one practice in a room all singing 60
people 45 of them have tested positive
for kovat 19 it being in the same room
with people who are talking much less
singing rejecting and singing just
breathing is it is is a risk it's like
this is again it's just not this isn't
it is not rocket science it is science
but it isn't a mystery it's not a
surprise as people you didn't know this
was going to happen we don't this is a
how quickly it's spreading no it's it is
not it's people who have been talking
about it the whole time
why are we so surprised so alright let's
take a let's take a short it's scary
it's I just want to get the scary part
out of the way so that on the back side
of this break we can be more positive
because now I'm I'm worked up and I know
what someone's tough we're gonna talk
about we're gonna get worked up again so
I'm gonna go work tell it but you know I
mean there's me there's people dying I
mean you know Joe Diffie is dead man
right poor guy you know it's like I I
have a lot of good memories too Joe
Diffie songs I actually felt really sad
you know it's like but he does have he
has the quintessential song about what
to do to him after he dropped me up
beside the jukebox when I die and if I
want to go to heaven but I don't want to
go tonight the main thing that I thought
about is the fact that I just don't feel
as prepared as Joe Diffie
are they gonna do that to him are they
gonna is he currently propped up beside
put some put a stiff drink in my hand
fill my boots up with sand sadly and I'm
not joking I know it seems that we're
making light of Joe diffie's death we're
not I think the reason that it's not
gonna happen is because of this damn
virus it's like if he had died in
another way during normal times they
might actually be considering that but
there's no but you can't have a girl you
can't have a funeral I mean you can have
an all line song about famous people
that you're fond of dying I mean they're
heart-wrenching tragic stories I just
can't bring myself to read a bottom
anymore of people people's loved ones
passing away and it's you know I let's
not get into it but it's it's scary and
it's it's taking too long to sink in and
it's taking again two weeks ago it was
said by the people who were trying to
get it to sink in it is it's it's not
gonna happen until people start dying
until people you love start dying yeah
that's what it takes you know we have
this disconnect we have this disconnect
you know I've I operate out of this
disconnect a lot it's like you watch the
news
you you hear about bad stories it's like
that stuff happens to other people it
doesn't happen to me it doesn't happen
to people I don't it it must be a
defense mechanism because I'd like to
think I'm not the only one who has that
tendency we talked about it some last
week but I think there's a number of
reasons we can but I think there's some
positives we'll get into that we will
get positive but first what we're gonna
get positive right now because we're
gonna let you know that we are
continuing to sell the 3d ymb shirt be
your mythical best shirt with a portion
of the proceeds going to feeding America
and Layne do you have the copy for what
feeding America is doing I had it but my
computer is having so many problems I
had to shut the program that had that
information about what feeding America
is specifically doing during the
outbreak feeding America is a nation
that wide network of to hunt I can't
even got numbers I said for 200 food
banks working to ensure our most
vulnerable populations continue to have
access to food and their greatest need
right now is donations and support of
local food banks so yeah the t-shirt
benefits feeding America you can also
donate yourself so mythical calm so so
how do we want to get into some well
some positivity I I want to talk a
little bit about just this idea of
conservation and how that applies
personally and then what that might mean
for the world because are you tell me
you tell my leftovers yeah well I'm not
going back to that specifically but I am
saying that it has made the scarcity or
at least the perceived scarcity of some
of these goods toilet paper for who
knows why being one of the chief ones
that there's a perceived scarcity of
toilet paper that's not actually true
there's just a few people who have it
all and I don't think they've got
especially dirty buttholes
I just think they got they got panicked
yeah the this perceived scarcity has
changed the way that I approach my my
meals but
so the amount of you know toilet paper I
do use paper towels like McLaughlin
family is we can go through a saplings
worth of paper towels like in a meal
sometimes just just a disregard for how
much we are consuming and this is a
problem in America this problem in the
Western world but the thing is is that
you know as these these developing
nations become industrialized and they
kind of move into this you know consumer
based culture they're all consuming at
the same rate right we know that's a
problem like the earth has been sort of
shouting for a while like this is the
problem there's not enough if you're all
gonna act this way but it makes me think
yeah as I was trying to evaluate what
how what did what's this doing to me
personally I was thinking about Jesse's
grandmother who died last year I think
she was 92 so she was basically born
right around the time of the depression
and she had this tendency to be
incredibly like she would conserve in
like ways that we would laugh at like
she would put aluminum foil over some
food and then she would like serve it
and then she would take the aluminum
foil off and she would wash it and she
would fold it back up and put it back in
the drawer I mean this woman used
aluminum foil over and over again in
fact one time went Christmas her sister
aunt Betty got her aluminum foil or tin
foil as they called it as we called it
in the south for Christmas that was a
Christmas present and those things that
suddenly she could throw it away more
readily okay just because she knows how
much she values it it's just like toilet
paper has become currency that's my
bottom II thing with toilet paper you
could try it okay if you draw a picture
of George Washington on it it'll
definitely work but yeah just this idea
that it's like hmm there is a limited
amount of stuff but not just that but I
think it
draws into focus for me this idea that
the steady stream of goods is always
going to be there like we took it for
granted that everything that we need is
always going to be there you don't have
to stock up you don't have to have extra
of anything you don't have to be
prepared for anything now you know me
and being a prepper light I do have
quite a bit of stuff ready but it's not
life subtle stuff yeah but it's like
emergency I haven't gone into any of it
yet because it's just like freeze-dried
food do you think so you're saying that
you think this will affect your
lifestyle moving forward I think it will
and I think I think it will my hope is
that it will change the way our kids you
know because I think the only people who
really have a sense of of this are
probably boomers because they kind they
were at least it can have it kind of
remember a time where things were a bit
a little bit less available but and
they've they've all bought into the same
lie that we that we've all bought into
that we can get whatever we want
whenever we want it and it doesn't end
and the consequences is it doesn't
matter what that means about people it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter what it
means about the earth you know but I
think we're beginning to see that no
there's consequences to that hyper
consumerism it not just this idea of
conservation as well I don't know if
it's going to be there but just
beginning to examine hold on it's not
that the support it's not just that the
supply chains are susceptible to things
like a virus it's not that the fact that
we've got a global economy and we're and
we're getting our stuff from other
places that then could be affected and
we're all interdependent and that's and
we're susceptible to certain things
that's all true but it just makes for me
a cut there's been a few things through
that throughout this that have just kind
of begun to seem a little gross and one
of them is this this idea that we can
have whatever we want as much of it as
we want whenever we want
it just seems but if you're responsible
act achill it's not going to take hold
like I
think it has to come down to okay I'm
out of paper towels I cannot get more
paper towels so I'm gonna start using
hand towels and then I'm gonna put them
in the laundry what we have a few rolls
of paper towels left and I'm thinking
about just taking them out because we
have we have hand towels
yeah and once you discover a hand towel
works just as good as a paper towel
it's just especially if you're a kid and
you're not the one doing laundering the
the hand towels there's no impact to you
you know except okay now that I've wiped
up this thing or I've wiped my hands or
whatever I don't know where to put it
oh you got well you need to hang it up
and let it dry and you can use it again
you don't you don't have to just throw
it away so it's really just a habit and
it's once you exchange to doing the hand
towels and you get used to it for a few
weeks or a few months I think at that
point then you can say you know what
let's not go back I'm using much less
toilet paper I'm I'm using my bidet to a
whole new level
oh the bidet is you know I was smartest
thing I've ever bought in my life but I
I realize how much toilet paper I was
still using in combination with my bidet
and I'm like you know what I shouldn't
have to use mmm two squares and that's
just - just a DAB off just well there is
there is an air dryer but it takes
forever it takes too long and it doesn't
doesn't really work and also does sends
the toilets tank throughout your room
but I I think when you it can't be an
ideological change of mind it has to be
a habitual change of mine and I think as
the week's go on that's what will make
the difference so but then I think
there's and I think that's positive I
think another positive when I talk about
the groceries coming in and you know I'm
talking about how stressful that is and
everything but I'm also thinking you
know what
it took me 30 minutes to wipe everything
down but in the long run when this is
over I'm not gonna be why
anything down and by the way how long
would it have taken to shop for all
these groceries that I just spent all
this time wiping down if they weren't
delivered to me I saved all that time
man grocery deliveries pretty nice even
if I don't get exactly what I want they
swap it out with something else and
there's a little bit of a surprise you
don't know exactly what you're gonna get
look at what I got today it feels like
I'm going back to a milkman experience
man I always wonder what that would be
like who left a milkman seer I wonder
what kind of milk I got he's a
strawberry is it chocolate did they do
that I don't think so I think it's
mostly just milk unless your milk man
was a Nesquik rabbit mine wasn't because
I never well I in there's some people
who I know they they do like the the
grocery delivery but the vast vast vast
majority of people don't don't do that
you go and you shop for your groceries
because well you know I'll remember
something else that I need or this will
strike my fancy but we're actually
learning even with so many things being
swapped out there like we had a crap ton
of groceries come yesterday and it's
gonna last us a few weeks because
they're trying to minimize the amount of
touch points that we have with new
deliveries I think that's something
that's gonna keep going like I mean the
way that shopping has moved to Amazon
over the past five years the whenever I
want something the first thing I think
is Amazon except for groceries and I
think this is putting me over the edge
to like have groceries delivered but I
think that's another silver lining well
but how okay but that's I find that
somewhat problematic right because the
the whole Amazon thing you know Amazon
has its own issues that it's dealing
with you know I think that in any any
major company like that that is trying
to serve that many people and do it for
profit I'm not singing in order from
Amazon it's an order from your local
well no what you think that ml but I'm
saying you have to you have to evaluate
like that may make your life easier and
it may get you off of the road but it is
also putting a delivery person on the
road meaning that from like a carbon
standpoint I don't know I don't know
I've never looked into this I don't know
which one is more but I think one of the
things is like I have a tendency for
instance when I order stuff from Amazon
as I think of it I'll just order it and
it just it's it's one trip it's one box
whereas there's there's a more
responsible way to do that to put things
into a larger order justice that's a
small thing that then okay I can make
this one trip from one delivery person
as opposed to three or four but I do
think that some of those but I but what
I'm asking is what we're really talking
about what in the future what it what
how are our future lives going to be
different because of this experience and
I'm just saying I'm gonna be ordering a
bunch of things that I didn't order
before I think groceries is is the chief
among stuff yeah well let's talk about
what you were talking about earlier
which is we can get back more into the
like the societal financial sciency
stuff in a second but the Greek that
yeah the idea the idea of greetings I
mean obviously at some point well I
don't think I'll ever go back to a
handshake okay let's put it simply well
because there's an acceptable
alternative for it but but before get to
handshake so just the idea of being in
closed spaces with people right I mean
one of the things that I've been
noticing is as I watch television and I
see groups of people like crowded places
I can't help but think about the virus
now that's that's gonna go away like
we're not gonna be a species that no
longer gathers together in public spaces
but I mean this particular you know
depending on who you talk to you I mean
and there's a range of predictions but
we're prot this is probably going to be
something that subsides a little bit
the summer and it comes back again in
the fall it looks like it's gonna have
some seasonality to it we're not gonna
have a vaccine by the fall I doubt I
mean that would be an unprecedent a
timeline maybe that'll happen but it
doesn't look like it will and so we may
actually be dealing with it even a year
after that so this particular virus may
be something that affects public
gatherings for 18 to 24 months but I
think eventually when we get past this
we're gonna be thinking differently
about it but the thing is and again
comparisons how we're going here's how
I'm gonna be thinking differently about
it I'm not gonna shake hands I'm not
gonna be touching railings I'm like all
the stuff that everybody touches I'm I'm
gonna be I'm gonna have an instinct to
not touch those things because now I
have an appreciation for how easily
things can be on how germs can be on
there like I might be more of a
germaphobe man I think I'm just gonna
I'm gonna have my hand in my sleeve and
I'm gonna be opening doorknobs or I
already whenever I would push on a door
I would I would think about the place
where the least number of people push
especially children so I'll reach really
high and then push on it I've been doing
that for years but I didn't even I
couldn't even tell you exactly why I was
doing it I was like yeah because a lot
of people touch there and that's gross
but I hadn't really made the connection
that now is like firmly in place that's
there is something there that then will
be on me that then will go in my mouth
I'm how I'm in telling this thing man
well what the question is is that we're
gonna go all the way back yeah but my
question is is if everyone began to bet
I I'm split on this because I feel like
if everyone behaves in this
hyper-vigilant way during normal times
right now but during normal times
everybody's using hand sanitizer
everybody's avoiding each other nobody's
talking I mean nobody's touching
nobody's shaking hands somebody's
touching doorknobs and stuff like that
everybody's putting hand sanitizer on
every surface
I need to talk to an expert on this but
my my fart is that that may make us as a
species long term more susceptible to
things I mean one of the reasons yeah
one of the reasons that when you know if
you read Guns Germs Guns Germs and Steel
like one of the reasons that when the
Western Europeans when they came to
America they very few of them died and
many of the Native Americans died was
because because the Native Americans did
not have doorknobs yeah if they they had
been living in these open spaces and
they weren't like crowded together but
all that wasn't Europeans had been in
cities and gathered together so they had
all this resistance to viruses we're
gonna keep these viruses are gonna keep
coming you're gonna have a lot more
deaths from falling because people
aren't gonna be using handrails Betsy
that's that's a dud see people aren't
gonna be themselves like I'm gonna this
is how I'm gonna go now because of this
experience
well I'm but I'm telling you down
something no but what I'm saying is that
if everyone does what you're doing it
may actually make us more susceptible to
the next round because there will be
another round I don't know I will have
fallen downstairs before that happens
but yeah but it makes me think
differently about it makes me think
differently about just flu season in
general I don't I don't think about flu
season now and I know the comparisons
between kovat and flu or unhelpful very
unhelpful but the fact is is that the
seasonal flu if it's a bad one kills
thousands of people and what kills
people every year sometimes tens of
thousands of beautiful and I don't get
the flu shot I mean I very rarely get
the flu shot but but and the reason I
don't get it is because I feel
personally invincible so I I think like
oh I might get the flu but it's not
gonna kill me this is I have to make an
appointment but now I'm thinking about
my own I'm not just thinking about my
own situation I'm thinking about how I
contribute to every out situation so my
never learn about the flu shot yet
you're getting the flu shot like not
about ie
about society you
the flu shot is about the people who I
might come in contact with that are
susceptible and not being the a-hole
who's like oh I might get the flu and
that I might interact with someone who's
susceptible and and they die it's like
oh it's not that's a big change for me
but but I do think it it's gonna also I
think the greeting thing is a big thing
because there's currently an alternative
and I there's no way there's zero chance
that shaking of hands and getting
together and getting really close to
each other in large and in tight
environments is gonna be a regular thing
in 2020 like that's not coming back in
2020 hmm you know I'm not saying that
when it's um gathering it's not coming
back soon I mean when you when concerts
and going to the movies and parties
start happening again well I think
there'll be a little bit of Sun we
appreciate it and then there'll be time
when we're old when we'll say oh you
know you can go to parties anytime you
want but to is a time when we couldn't
do that could we party here get a party
in your house Artie on a video chat
could what about video chats how do you
think video tests which are I mean
everybody's doing it
I can't you enjoy you more via video
chat so I mean maybe we can conduct our
whole relationship like this you don't
mean that
that's just like planning that you've
said I can't hear you chewing
interestingly even though there's your
problem
I was eating cereal when we were doing
last week we're doing the test the
technical tests I was eating cereal and
you seem to be able to hear it yes
really
I actually I could quite a bit for some
because it's all you know the reason I
couldn't really hear things recorded
that GMM because your Bert's
you were eating a lick we were drinking
liquids your chai wasn't chewing it so I
take out all back rather be in person
better I'd rather be next to you III
think I think it's good for really I
think a whole group of people I think
the majority of people are realizing
that they can can conduct a meaningful
conversation and a meaningful
relationship on a screen mm-hmm
and I just think that a lot of people
who were making phone calls before are
going to be making video chats moving
forward well think about the video chat
that we had with our close friends from
college you know we we have been in
contact loose contact with these guys
who were like our best friends in
college and you know many many months
via text many many months would go by
where we wouldn't there would be no
contact at all but then we recently
reconnected and we started like a
whatsapp chat and then during all this
since everyone has sort of figured out
the video chat thing we were like listen
like we got a resume call and nothing
changed about our proximity it wasn't
like we used to be together like last
year and now we're apart so like no we
went to college together but we got on
and we had this you know we talked to
each other I think people are getting
over the awkwardness of it I think it
there's the technological barrier like I
don't know how to do it you know which
everyone can do it at this point a young
you know who can do it but also there's
an awkwardness to it to a video chat
that that you get over I think if
everyone is being forced to get over it
really quickly yeah so I think it's
drastically accelerated that type of
relationship and that type of connection
I mean I I think about how far I am from
family members and I just think that
there's a there's a greater chance of
being more connected when this thing is
over as a result of this which is which
is nice you know I mean the kids have
started schooling over video chats and
they're figuring all that out and making
sure you know they remember that people
can see them and that people can hear
them unless they turn their camera off
you know it's like is this new awareness
of whenever I'm in front of a screen
people are gonna start to assume that
they're being watched versus the
opposite because we're gonna learn that
lesson well and also the idea I think
that's something we won't go back and
we'll have this we'll have this
comfort level with being seen and heard
and basically watched whenever were on a
screen it'll be the exception it'll be
the rule not the exception but people
are learning their lesson I don't know
if you saw there was a zoom chat that
the video of a portion of the video from
it went viral a couple weeks ago where
there was a work video chat and one of
the women on the call
like has her computer and then all of a
sudden let you see her get up and walk
like down the hall and then all of a
sudden she sets a laptop down on the
bathroom floor the camera is pointing
right up on her she pulls in her pants
and pees what yes and like you hear and
there's the main person who's talking
who's like leading the discussion starts
like who slows down a little bit and
everybody starts looking and like
covering their mouths laughing and stuff
why didn't it what do they say hey Tina
what note she like looking down girl she
like looks down while she's peeing and
sees her legs on the screen and like
suddenly like closes the laptop oh my
gosh people are in another example of my
dad was in a call with some people
recently like a zoom call and like he
and like his you know people in of you
know in in 60s and 70s who he's also
having these meetings with they they
started well his friend was like okay
I'm hosting this zoom call and we're
gonna start the meeting at like 6
o'clock but you can get on the zoom call
at any time that you want kind of like
just talk or whatever and like my dad
goes on there like 4 o'clock just like
to check to make sure everything's
working and like he can hear this guy
and his wife having a conversation in
their house because they haven't muted
themselves so I think one of the things
that's going to happen is people there's
this adjustment period people are gonna
be caught doing and saying things about
other people that thing that always
happens sometimes when you realize that
you're you're saying something about
someone that you wouldn't want them to
hear and you're like oh did I actually
but dial them right before this this
happened like or is this conference call
muted
yeah did I hit mute or did I hit mute
and I'm you really quickly and now I'm
saying something that they're hearing
yeah I mean and Lily was watching this
tick tock sketch last night and I happen
to look over her shoulder and it was
some-some girl of course that she didn't
know she wasn't dancing she was doing
something comedic which was nice she was
crying
for for for the laughs why is his girl
crying well then she goes on to talk
about how when you're in your classroom
chat if you like read the fine print it
says this what well when you're in your
your video classroom that the chat
feature on the side is permanently
recorded and the teacher can see that
not only can the teacher see after the
fact the entire chat that's taking place
they can also see the private messages
between students in the classroom I'll
listen I actually don't assume I don't
know I don't know which and I actually
don't know if it's true but she was
making fun of it and I kind of can
believe it but again I don't know first
it seems that's kind of like a flaw in
the system if that's the case well being
able to see the the classroom chat then
well that seems right later as the huh
seems right but the private lines direct
messages they're just direct messages
between students it's like yes should
the teacher be able to hear what two
students are whispering to each other in
the back of the classroom no I don't
think so I don't think so either
so maybe she was wrong and it's just
sending shock waves through tick-tock
and also to me you'd have to look into
that yourself but that's one thing
working from home that's another thing I
mean first of all I do not like it I'm
sure there are people who are
discovering that they can work from home
and they can get everything done and
they can those people don't have
children there's more yeah there's more
freedom associated with or whatever I
mean it is gonna change the the
workplace landscape there's gonna be
there's gonna be their savings
associated with it did
the business I guess oh I think one of
the biggest changes that will take place
I mean yeah definitely people who have
like brutal commutes will find ways to
work from home because a lot of people
are instituting work from home policies
out of necessity
now some businesses can't continue to
function working from home but a lot of
them can and so those people who kind of
once you find a way for weeks yeah and
you're like I must I at least give me my
Friday at home and my Monday yes it
actually makes decisions it's it can be
a beneficial thing for a lot of for a
lot of reasons because you got somebody
who's working from home therefore
they're not driving you know so they're
not they're not contributing carbon to
the to the atmosphere by driving but
they're also not wasting an hour or two
hours or whatever just being on the road
and so they they've got more free time
and then the employer if that person
doesn't actually have to be present the
employer doesn't have to provide a space
for them which means a smaller building
like there's there's a there's
definitely a lot but I think that one of
the practical ways that it'll be
implemented is right now when you're
sick one of the reasons you stay home is
you feel like crap another reason you
stay homeless so you don't become you
don't affect other people that is gonna
happen a lot more people are gonna be
like I'm sick I actually think I could
probably work but it would be
irresponsible for me to go in and also I
can do my job from home and I can go
into this meeting via videoconference
having people who are at home sick or
just needed to stay home to do something
because they had a doctor's appointment
or because they needed to watch their
kid suddenly those people it's not going
to be weird to pipe them in on a video
conference because we will all have the
experience in doing it and it's not like
oh the person on the video chat is
somehow less of a contributor or less
significant because we all remember that
time when we were all on video chats I
think that's gonna be a huge huge change
it's gonna change the way sick leave is
looked at because you're gonna be able
to stay home and your aunt WIC but
you're still working
and we're gonna have to figure out what
what does that mean for how do you for
hourly employees what does that look
like what does that mean all right and
I'll shift it one more time because then
I know you want to talk about this but
so I'll just tee it up the the view of
science and scientists what they're what
they're saying to us yeah I hope that
that changes in a positive way as a
result of this because if you look back
weeks ago at what what what science what
what science in scientists were saying
about what most likely will happen and
now it is and we didn't want to hear it
we didn't want to come to grips with it
it's so we opted for it to get worse
before we started to do enough I hope
there's a lesson learned that it
translates into the silver lining well
there's definitely lesson learned there
okay this has been very discouraging to
me this has been incredibly infuriating
honestly now I've been infuriated with
people who refuse to listen to plain
science for a long time but this the
timescale of what we knew and then how
we could everything has been condensed
and clarified in this situation now this
is a distinct it's not distinctly but it
is very much an American issue right
like I can't imagine what the rest of
the world is thinking they're like you
guys there's so much like Pride and
being in America being an American but
yet we're what we lead the world in in
many ways is just almost aggressive
ignorant it's like this isn't where the
really were the only place in the world
right now that's experiencing this this
pandemic to this degree where people the
general population has a distinctly
polarized opinion about what's actually
happening because of the political
polarization in our country which is
just mind-blowing to me now more and
more people who
who played it down including our
president are coming around to the
reality and beginning to listen to the
people who said this all along but the
things that I've heard like it's in his
taking bodies in refrigerated trucks
outside of hospitals for that to happen
yeah right but the thing is is that but
and I want it I just want to redeem that
I want to redeem those those bodies and
you know I want I want to know that we
won't make these mistakes again go ahead
but I think that okay there's lots of
people saying that no one knew this was
gonna happen I've heard that so many
times no one could have known this was
happening what are you freaking nuts
no it's we've been being warned about
this for so many people for so many
years that this exact scenario with this
exact timeline with the exact
exponential curve of infections and
deaths even where it potentially would
come from like all this was very much
written on the wall said in TED talks
written in books written in articles and
anyone who is paying attention even a
little bit should not have been
surprised by this but in one sense it's
very difficult to be prepared because if
you think about it from a political
standpoint it would be very difficult
especially in our country to convince
people that disaster preparedness on
this level for a pandemic was worth
investing in right it's like where
everyone's struggling to figure out what
we're gonna do with our money if
somebody is like guys we're gonna have a
surplus of masks and ventilators you're
gonna get votes for that know everybody
like you're crazy why are you spending
all that money on something that it's
not gonna it might not happen so it took
not really won't happen
it took an event like this but the thing
is is that because what we're talking
about is I think there in America there
is this distrust of authority which is a
good thing right but there is a distrust
of expertise which is a bad thing and
people have lumped them together so the
whole idea of questioning Authority you
know people talk like they're like you
can never do a lockdown in the US like
you did in China
because we don't have an authoritarian
government and I think that and also the
whole point like the principle founding
principle of America is independence
from an oppressive government right and
so I think that that's a healthy thing I
think that questioning authority is is
there's a healthy positive place for
that but in the past generation or so
that has gotten conflated with
questioning expertise and thinking that
people who are experts in certain areas
scientists namely are part of a deep
state conspiracy from all sorts of
issues but again they've been saying it
from the very beginning they were like
okay this is when it's gonna get here
there was literally a dude who said this
will be beginning to infect large
numbers of people in the US the week of
March so-and-so or whatever he said that
in January and you know what happened
that week is the week that it was oh now
we've got clusters we got community
spread is he a prophet does he have a
crystal ball no he just has studied this
before but that doesn't keep a bunch of
stupid-ass people from going on Facebook
and talking about something they have no
idea about like the amount of drivel
that has come out of people's mouths and
off of people's keyboards these armchair
experts it's like I don't know about
this stuff I'm not gonna claim to know
about I haven't I haven't read these
books I haven't studied this but I can
recognize when someone has and
understand that oh they're all saying
basically the same thing there it may be
a range of projections but they're all
basically saying the same thing they're
all saying this is gonna seem like we're
overreacting but just trust us these
things operate according to very
established principles very established
mathematical projections and this is
what's going to happen and here's what
we have to do to minimize that and now
one of the things I'm already seeing
it's just because the level the
projections have come down people are
like I told you that experts were wrong
they said that two million people were
going to die and now they're saying that
200,000 going to die
see science fails again it makes me want
to harm someone when I hear people say
things like that but because the simple
reality is the projections have changed
because the practices that the experts
suggested are being implemented we want
the projections to change and some
people in some governor's and some
leaders have actually said you're
actually going to get ahead of this and
we're going to institute these things
before they become a huge problem yeah
we want the projections to change
because we want people to actually do
what the experts are suggesting but
again there is this tendency to question
to be like I think I might I think I
might know more than this because I have
a communications degree you know it's
like I I don't I don't understand it's
not just southern people who have these
opinions by the way but well the reason
I go into that southern accent is
because that's where I'm from where I'm
from that's the best way to characterize
that mentality now so as a southern man
with a southern accent I have the right
to go into a southern accent to make fun
of people and I stand by that until it
becomes offensive in 2025 and then I'll
stop it's okay but he has come from this
I think that well yeah yeah i okay so a
couple people have I'm not this isn't
something I came up where the number of
people have made this connection but
this is there's very little difference
between this and climate change right
again in America it's the only nation on
earth where there's like a legitimate
like a large section of the population
that doubts the reality of manmade
climate change that humans are causing
climate change and also climate change
stands the potential to be catastrophic
and as we're already beginning to see
the effects right there's a huge group
of people driven by not science but
ideology who think that this just all a
scam when the people who have devoted
their lives to
studying this who are not part of a deep
skate deep state conspiracy who are just
people who are after the truth have been
sounding the warning bells and they've
said this is what's going to happen
these are the projections this is the
worst-case scenario this is the
best-case scenario but this is the range
of scenarios based on what we're doing
right now and if we don't adopt these
drastic measures
then this many people could die now it's
not as precise and it's not a short term
as the kovat 19 thing but it's all the
same factors are in play you got people
who don't know anything about the
situation who go on a website and find
some information and then paired it on
Facebook and everybody you know there's
so much false information that is
parroted there's that there's this idea
that people who believe in climate
change are part of a deep state
conspiracy there's a lot of people who
are like even if climate change is real
we can't implement the measures that the
scientists are suggesting because it'll
kill our economy again another thing
that is perfectly in line with covin 19
and maybe just maybe and it's again like
you said is taking people being in
refrigerated trucks for people to see
this these guys who were not motivated
by anything other than a desire to
understand and communicate the truth
have been saying this have been warning
us and here's what's happening see what
we said what's gonna happen is happening
and how to prevent it is exactly how we
said we should prevent it and yes it is
going to negatively affect the economy
on some to some degree but we'll get
through it and we will recover I just
the same principles or unless to think
that we as humans are and especially as
Americans are learning our lesson to
listen to the scientists and to take
action to take drastic action for
something that's
that is happening drastic things are
happening but you know you see you see
glaciers melting who cares you know you
show the sad polar bear it's a it's it's
cyclical man it was simply and you the
wildfires what what all the natural
disasters it's just I'm just afraid that
not enough people are going to learn a
lesson from this - well here's the
here's the great news you don't have to
have a lot of them learn their lesson
you just have to have enough to change
policy that's the beautiful thing about
our country is you don't have to have 98
percent of people agree right now we
have we have a political ideology in
this country that while there are some
healthy questioning Authority things
that come from that ideology some other
things had been glommed on to including
this distrust of expertise and so that
group of people are driving policy and
keeping real change from happening but
we were almost there we were almost
there as a country we were moved both
parties were kind of aligned and said
this is a real deal we need to take some
action and then 2016 happened and a lot
of things are moving in the wrong
direction but what I'm getting at is I
feel like this is going to impact some
people's mentality to be like hmm maybe
maybe I shouldn't just read a book or go
on a website and just suddenly think
that 97% of the people who study this
are wrong I just don't know how
catastrophic this needs to be and it
already is in many ways people's lives
are wrecked
people's people are dying people's
people's livelihoods are disintegrating
but I don't know how bad it needs to get
for it to really shake us up permanently
in order to be able to apply these
lessons to
my change because it it's so applicable
but I'm just afraid that I don't know
cuz it the worse it gets the more money
we're gonna have we're gonna have to
spend and band together in order to
rebuild the economy now we're gonna want
to stern route and also spend a lot of
money to you know all the support
structures we're putting in place to get
everyone back on their feet and get the
economy back on his feet are things that
are part of the green New Deal - to
accommodate for people who are in
industries which are harming the
environment in order to give them a
support structure to continue to be a to
be a contributing part of the economy in
society you know and not to for their
lives not to their life as well -
disintegrate so it's just but gonna
spend a lot of money to fix this this
problem of kovin 19 is there gonna be
any money left over to spend on this
initiative that like by the way it's not
something that's predicted that might
happen it it also is happening that's
something again I the president keeps
saying hopefully this won't happen again
for centuries it's like dude what well
what it's going to happen again we knew
that it was going to happen they said it
was going to happen and it will happen
again and it will happen more often
actually the more we continue to grow
and there's more people and being
crowded travel and connections I mean
it's a lot different it was a hundred
days ago but I think that the the good
news something that we can be hopeful
about with what you said is that first
of all there are things happening as a
result of this virus that directly
impact carbon emissions right and I'm
not just talking about like factories
being shut down which you know are you
know all of a sudden there's no tourism
and Venice Italy so the canals are clear
for the first time in recent memory
that's not a sustainable thing we don't
want there to be no tourists we want
people to travel we want people to make
things we do want the economy to come
back but something as simple as thinking
differently about consumerism and
consumption that is going to have an
impact on just the amount of goods that
are
and what we think we actually need and I
think that that is going to have a
positive impact on climate this so these
supply chains being so global which I
think it's great that we're connected as
humans in us and are the imaginary
borders that we place around ourselves
or we're beginning to see that they are
just that they're imaginary you can't
keep the virus out the virus doesn't
know that there's a border around your
country doesn't see it see people the
way that people see people but we
necessarily will have to move
manufacturing closer to the people who
need those manufactured goods and that
is going to have a drastic impact
because basically when we when all this
stuff got outsourced globally and all
the stuff is being produced in mass
quantities and then shipped all around
the world all of that has increased
carbon emissions drastically but if we
bring those supply chains back closer to
home it'll be good for local economies
it'll be good for the environment so I
think that I think that part of the
economic recovery because of this could
actually have some of those green
technologies and strategies so which
ultimately will in the long term make us
healthier as an economy and be able to
address the depressing problems of
climate change I'm trying to be there is
hope like trying to be hopeful trying to
be positive you know it's like I mean it
that is the exercise I mean that is the
challenge for all of us is to whether
we're looking to the future or looking
to the next five minutes is that we need
to continue and I'm shifting gears here
in order to conclude this thing it's our
it's our challenge to remain positive
and to channel our energy into things
that enrich our lives and the lives of
other people so you know how many weeks
is this going to go on I don't know
we're gonna keep having these
discussions every week be a part of a
hashtag your biscuits let us know what
you think about these like predictions
that we've made
but also you know I just want to take it
as an opportunity to encourage you to to
love yourself and love those around you
and if and and that includes the people
around you via video chat to just
channel your energy into things that
enrich your lives and the lives of
others and continue to find the silver
linings I think with where we are I I
don't know that we did a great job of it
today you know it's like I I I tend to
have this like first you know like when
I think about everything we've been
talking about there's there's still a
lot of frustration that's coming out and
it's it's hard to have a light-hearted
discussion when these things are going
on and I yeah that's good the game every
how things are I think these things it's
good to be frustrated about these things
yeah because we deserved better you know
than the response that we've gotten and
people should have been more responsible
people should have listened to the
experts
you shouldn't have to see people die in
order to believe that someone who has
devoted their lives to studying
something that is pretty well understood
we're telling you the truth you know so
it is something to get upset about
because Pete listen people that
mentality the mentality of not believing
experts has directly led to an untold
number of deaths already yeah it will
continue to lead to more deaths so
that's something that's worth being
upset of it yeah it's okay to be upset
about that's right but again like you
said Joe diffie's death will not be in
vain because you know ironically when
people see that these these people that
they look up to that they loved died
whether they be everyone will know
someone yeah who suffered from this and
many people will know someone who died
personally but you'll also people who
have created things that you that you
love are gonna die from this and I think
little by little it's sinking into more
and more people and I there's no way
that that can't have some sort of
charitable impact on people so it won't
be all in vain
I'll give a recommendation is my week if
you haven't hunkered down and watched
Lord of the Rings get your hand on the
extended versions you got you know the
longer the movie the better and the the
versions that we watch more the extended
ones and then we started watching the
extras which is my actual recommendation
because we've already made the
recommendation of the movies well do you
mind long my family is going extended
through the extras now but you know how
long the extended version of Return of
the King is let's see it goes for I get
three hours two three and a half it's
four hours and 52 minutes what I bought
it last night but could I I had the DVD
set extended edition and you know me I
was it I've cleaned out so much stuff
over the past few years and like I just
get so aggressive I got rid of them
because they weren't they weren't
blu-ray and I was like I can just rent
them online well it turns out you can't
you have to buy the extended version
especially if you want to see all the
extras you can see some of them on
YouTube which we've watched but they're
like varying quality I don't know you
get your kids to sit through that they
love it my kids regardless of the movies
are but my kids my kids my kids my
lovers monstrous well no but I'm talking
about the length of the movie so my kids
love the movies but then like we'll be
getting into the third air hour and
they're like how long is this movie dad
like it isn't like I'm ready to stop
watching it but it's like they don't
watch things that are that long and the
idea of this watching a movie for four
hours and 52 minutes well I would divide
it up into three sittings which we you
have again you we can do that but my
kids are really getting hooked on the
production like I think they're all
wanting to be like movie producers now I
may change their mind next week but like
it's the most in-depth behind-the-scenes
footage of any movie and there's no
movie as worthy of it as Lord of the
Rings in my opinion so I think it's
worth the $50 to buy the whole knee and
make sure you get the extended version
not the theatrical version when you buy
the blu-ray DVDs so that you get the
extended scenes as well as the extras
that's my recommend hash tag ear
biscuits yeah we'll keep talking we're
not we promise that we're you know we're
not gonna keep talking about the virus
there are other things happening and
there's other things to talk about so
we'll talk about something different
next week or maybe we want it I don't
know what I'm going to talk about next
week well but we'll also invite you into
the conversation because I really
enjoyed when we we talked about
everybody's secret hobbies or whatever
yeah I've talked about so we're gonna
have something different but what keep
we'll keep talking about this as long as
we're doing it but we're not gonna do it
next week we'll take a break from the
heavy stuff
but we will do an episode so we'll talk
about you next week every week every
week to watch more ear biscuits click on
the playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]